ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla oh sorry i mean coffee time
and today we're talking about the rise
of the finn fin fin fin fluencer the
finn fluencer can you imagine meeting
somebody hey what do you do i'm a finn
fluencer guys it's a new word saw this
just today i thought why not we're in
the we are talking all the time about
the ridiculous world of financial
knowledge financial um
learning and how ridiculous it's gotten
because now guys it used to be you
watched a youtube video instead of
reading a book now you watch a 10 second
tick tock guys these are the new
educators of today's day and age people
like this guy right here he's making
more than wall street bankers 500 000 a
year topping even young bankers now this
article is about as inane and insipid as
you might think
smash that like button wall street yeah
i think i've uh
[Music]
i've heard enough right high five
i've heard enough smash that like button
while sorry actually we do need the
board for this but today we're gonna
look through some of the great financial
advice of the finn the fin flu
the fake fluids are dad here to teach
teach you about
bitcoin
it's all about blockchain
about a bunch of wall street bankers are
looking to just be like i made a series
of severe and continuous mistakes i've
made a severe and continuous lapse in my
judgment now to be honest i kind of like
this guy i i think i'm learning stuff
block blockchain
i like it what but i have learned
nothing so far let's try to actually
learn something from the fin fluencer 10
000
that's how much the average price of a
pudgy penguin has gone up in a week the
pudgy penguins have absolutely blown up
in the past week with the floor price
now at 1.35 aetherium holy [ __ ]
this right here ladies and gentlemen
this man is the new jim cramer of wall
street the pudgy penguin maestro don't
hate him because he's richer than you
okay don't be a hater this is the new
coca-cola okay we had a we had exxon
mobil we had google this is the new
google this if you don't own one of
these you're on the outside you're not
on the modern uh this is what money is
now actually if you don't have one of
these you can't eat you can't go to heb
if you don't wait do people have hp you
can't go to walmart if you don't have a
pudgy penguin in your bank your wallet
and of course we don't have banks
because banks are the old way dude
blockchain
it's climbed up to be the fifth most
popular nft project and to keep it real
you guys i'm kind of new to this nft
stuff
you don't say guy makes like two million
dollars a year to be honest guys i'm a
little new to this stuff anyway here's
my private jet that i just rented oh
gosh this is incredible i've already i'm
already having a great time listen you
know what i gotta say though right off
the top more fun than actual stock
market analysis i do get it i do get why
people are watching this stuff way more
fun stock traders always have 20
monitors because what what what stock
traders always have 20 monitors is that
a thing because we need to see the hour
chart the five minute chart 30 minute
chart four hour chart the daily chart
the weekly chart and the monthly chart
all at one time what bro
you have a multiple charts oh what
monitor you got 20 monitors by the way
that's not 20. yo to confirm some of
this uh rock solid analysis i looked up
some pictures of stock traders here's
what looks like to be not a stock trader
only three monitors amateur hour now
this is what i'm talking about dude this
is this this is the setup of a real
trader right here dude if you don't have
this
i ain't investing if you don't actually
look like you're from the matrix itself
we're not buying dude what do you think
what do you take me for an investor dude
bro what are you a traditional investor
nah bro i'm a i'm a day trader dude i'm
a day trader i have to have the one pico
second chart up at all times dude i need
the one nanosecond chart otherwise how
am i supposed to trade intelligently
okay next advice here uh guys i don't
know if i'm gonna make this a thing i
like it though i like makes me feel like
a film director right the way these guys
feel like traders when they put 20
monitors in front of them they go i'm a
traitor now this is about crypt you guys
know we love crypto here we love small
cap coins dude that will inevitably
crash let's watch how he can become rich
how to become a billionaire no cap
sheesh moon if you want to become a
billionaire this is your best bet invest
1 000 best bet listen up guys buckle up
well actually it probably is your best
bet because you guys aren't going to
become a billionaire okay hey you're
watching coffee so let's get real here
let's get anybody who's watching youtube
uh ain't a billionaire right you think
jeff bezos watches us jeff bezos all in
chat
elon musk watches coffee's a lit no dude
not a chance sorry guys this might be
your best chance so ape into this
dollars into sheesh moon if that goes to
a one trillion dollar market cap it's at
135 000 right now that's a 7 million x
you make 7 billion bro 7 million x check
out dave yeah part of my calculation
you'll be going broke but uh you're on
tick tock what did you expect next
non-financial advice my hands feeling
kind of heavy my hair looks like
spaghetti don't make me go crazy i'm
just here looking pretty we're
celebrating where's the confetti because
bitcoin hit 40k already hey
i know you got that lust in bitcoin we
tried all these ladies are richer than
you okay
all you have to do it out to get rich
hey it's not actually about trading it's
about teaching people how to trade it's
about talking about bitcoin all the time
dude
oh my gosh dude i just love to imagine
they're all have net worths of like
50 million dollars and there's somewhere
some guy who worked for 50 years while
she's just crying right now or lady or a
lady oh by the way before we go to this
next one all of these come from the tik
tok investors twitter account guys
there's some absolute gold on there
thanks to him here we have a dude trying
to pick up my friend with his wells
fargo's account wtf
you really think that that is gonna
impress me it should
it should
first problem okay not using a coinbase
uh or binance account if you're look if
you're still on the fiat game fiat
you're not getting dude what do you
think you're gonna pull there nothing
dude i love just the confidence of you
think that's gonna impress me yes
you know a lot of us are gonna go show
our bank accounts be like yo you ever
seen three digits before huh
imagine picking up jeff bezos when he
was worth three digits okay imagine how
good of an investment that is seven
million x your investment by picking me
up right now money doesn't [ __ ]
oppress me i'm sorry it's just not
impressive
you're lost in life lady you heard of
garyvee hey you heard of grant cardone
what are you lost you never hunt you
don't hustle i don't know why i think
this is the move of hustlers but some oh
that that's the 10x 10x dude what money
doesn't impress me you go you're lost in
life
10x
i don't know why i'm acting like this
today i just i don't know if this is
either really funny or really stupid one
of the other that's okay oh and up next
guys we have a continuing saga now if
you guys don't know who this guy is he
sold all his fiat and invested it all in
bitcoin at sixty thousand dollars so
obviously a real winner uh put the
current price of bitcoin right here so
then in the last tick tock stocks video
we talked about how he moved in with his
parents now he is a he's a waiter now
which is fine it's cool but the most
recent update is uh more losses from
this guy so let's let's hear what's
going on with him i always like to keep
up with our favorite financial advisor
here hey coiners guys um
it's bad
i uh
i levered pretty hard at the top
i just thought at 52 000 i thought it
was going to go
i did what i
once again said i wasn't gonna do i
i just thought oh i need to listen to
bitcoin bill and he won key lever hard
at the top
the day before
this thing crashed 25
why do i feel like this is the only
honest guy on finto on the fin fluencer
side fin fluencer like i think most
people think they're going to look like
uh this you know when they join crypto
and stuff they're like yeah sell it sell
it sixty thousand dollars get my private
jet on the way you think you're this
you're you're actually this okay before
you go and become an influencer yourself
i want to talk to you guys about these
pudgy penguins because as we know from
this episode they are the greatest
investment this is the future but real
money real money is just pudgy penguins
from now on i do want to show you guys
this um twitter space room that they
were talking about pudgy penguins i want
you to hear about what the future of
finance looks like guys everyone knows
bankers are on the way out influencers
are on the way in and you need to know
what the future is if you're going to
retain a value in this current economy
like it's like back in the day you
traded wheat then you needed to buy
dollars if you didn't have dollars
you're out out of the loop right or gold
or whatever this is the future of
currency you need to understand it i
didn't understand it let's listen
together to what the greatest minds in
finance are talking about
and and that and i and my penguin is me
and i am my penguin
so true right
oh my gosh i was going through some
crazy things and and thank god like i
said i had some supportive people with
me along the way
i've had
some amazing people supporting me
and constantly lifting me up now the day
of the of the mint
i minted so many other projects and i
and i invested not money my me i
invested me into these projects hmm i
didn't know you could do that okay what
did it cost
me good go to a dealership that'll be
twenty thousand dollars sir nah i don't
pay in money ah i'm paying me good for
some reason when it came to the penguins
i didn't know much about cole i didn't
know much about mr tubby i didn't know
how amazing how influential be stupid
stop back up a few seconds i feel like
collectively we need to all hear that
part one more time i didn't know much
about mr tubby i didn't know how amazing
how influential these two people were
yeah it didn't make sense the second
time either i didn't know at that time
and
i didn't know what they were producing
and i said you know what i'll call out
on this one regardless of what everybody
was telling me i said you know what i'm
gonna call out on this one i'm gonna
save some money i have a girlfriend
let me take her out to a nice dinner
about this is my crying
and
i
find myself
in a group chat
with 18 whales
and all of them are telling me these
penguins call mr tubby
these
are people that we've never come across
before
the devs the discord the way that
they're managing all of
this this is absurd this is something
that's crazy this is something that we
have not seen before
i said i want to be a part of this
i bought my penguin
a few days later
this has
been the best damn thing i've ever done
in my entire life
what
this man this grown man is crying for
penguins the future has left us behind
ladies and gentlemen i feel like a lot
of people don't get what is this man
crying about some of you out there are
crying with them they're like i didn't
know tubby either
i didn't know what dubby could do
yeah dude he probably left his
girlfriend he took his girlfriend out
for dinner he's like girl hey baby i
gotta i'm on the phone with 19 whales
gotta go how do you think we're gonna
pay mortgage next week okay it's with
the penguins
oh my gosh dude i speak for everyone
when i say what a journey this has been
into the mind of the gen z
influenced influence or market i don't
know what to call it anyway that's
basically the takeaway i don't know i
think most people i speak for most
people we don't know i know i'm more
confused than ever but you know what you
don't have to be confused by is pumping
zilla guys it's free it costs nothing
like and subscribe if you like this big
investigations coming thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
a shame you're one fraud are you the
same it's true